(bright music)
(graphics whoosh)
When West Side Story's Ariana DeBose stopped by our show,
she didn't know she was about to become
an Academy Award nominee.
But we had a feeling.
Take a look at this extra special moment.
(graphics whoosh)
In what you portray with Anita, your capabilities,
your dance, your fire.
I mean, Rita Moreno won the Academy Award,
you deserve it too,
period.
(audience claps and cheers)
Oh my God I'm gonna cry!
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
(Ariana sniffing)
Oh my God, I'm really crying you guys,
this is terrible.
(audience exclaims softly)
Ah!
You do.
(Ariana laughs)
Because you put all of that work into it.
Years of effort and a triple threat.
There's so much that you accomplished in this movie.
It is the most firing, electric performance
I have seen in my life,
let alone in the last several years.
You are a revelation in this movie
as Anita.
(audience claps and cheers)
Thank you.
Thank you. (sobbing)
(audience clapping and whistling)
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it-
It's so true.
You know, it's, I don't know.
As a young girl, all I really wanted to do
was make movies.
I found theater first.
Or, perhaps it found me, gave me a home,
and then suddenly, I got the opportunity to start
making movies, and it's just been a dream come true.
You know?
And all I can say is like, just don't give up
on your dreams.
'Cause it will 9 times out of (chuckling) 10
turn out so much better than
you ever expect. (chuckles)
(audience claps)
(bright music)
(graphics whoosh)
Congratulations, Ariana.
It is so well-deserved, and we are cheering you on.